how does the status game relate to
cancel culture the idea that really made
sense of cancer culture for me was this
idea called the tyranny of the cousins
the groups in which we evolve very often
didn't have like a big leader who was in
charge that was really surprising to me
because when you look at human life
today there's leaders everywhere instead
there would be sort of a group of you
know Elders or relatively High status
people that would gather together to
make decisions at certain times
pre-modern groups are very much about
consensus or the illusion of consensus
you know it wasn't like somebody would
decide you're going to be punished it
was just this sense of consensus would
gather against this person and it would
be an atmosphere of of Gossip people
telling nasty stories about him and that
would that would create moral outrage
and more moral outrage would create more
consensus and it would build up and
build up and build up until this poor
bastard um was accused you know that is
exactly what you see on social media is
something that builds itself up in an
atmosphere of accusation gossip and
consensus and it kind of fires at this
person